former Republican governor and former
actor I guess current actor Arnold
Schwarzenegger has put out a fantastic
12-minute video condemning racism and
anti-Semitism and homophobia and
anti-trans rhetoric nobody who has
chosen the easy path of hate has gotten
to the end of the road and said oh what
a life
no
did die as miserably as they lived this
is interesting because Arnold can't be
written off by the right as just another
European or a soy boy liberal from
New York City or whatever else the case
may be Arnold is the epitome of the
alpha male that they love
action movie star Republican elected
official weight lifting the entire thing
and Arnold is making some really really
good points